the question at the end of the three is
who won III that's usually discussing
Microsoft Sony or Nintendo now all three
had great press conferences right
Microsoft had the Xbox one X now the
most powerful console out there and you
can just imagine what that'll mean for
games that come to it down the road
meanwhile Sony had a lot of great first
party games that we saw in the past and
a couple new announcements and those
games look great too ultimately I think
Nintendo had you know the most fruitful
presentation for their fans we got games
that we've been asking for for years
like my shirt prime for we've been given
Metroid Samus Returns or like total
shock like we got two Metroid games in
one year but I think most importantly we
got a release date for Super Mario
Odyssey and we've seen that this game is
nuts
it is bash crazy in a sense it's what
the series needs and I think it's really
going to make switched owners happy I've
played it and frankly I'm super excited
that's going to come out October 27th
I think Nintendo had the most news for
their fans and those people walked away
happier than most like a bunch of other
people I actually agree that Nintendo
did win of the three big players I think
Sony had a really strong showing with
their first party titles although the
conference was a little bit disjointed
and I think Microsoft was really good to
go just rifle through 42 games and of
course show off the Xbox one X but in
tendo with these surprises that were
Metroid Prime 4 and Metroid Samus
Returns those are great things for any
fan of the Nintendo library and I also
think that they gave us a bunch of
reasons to have a switch even more so
than just Zelda I'm particularly excited
for Mario + rabbits Kingdom battle never
thought I would say that before but that
game looks weird and awesome and as an
ex content I cannot wait for it
[Music]
so yeah Nintendo for the show one for me
I think for me result undoubtedly 1e3
they had the most exciting games
surprising games and I think a lot of
the other games on Microsoft and Sony's
stage were quite predictable of the
other two Microsoft had more of them but
nothing really blew us away there wasn't
a big Scorpio kind of oh sorry through
Xbox one X exclusive and Sony kind of
played it straight there wasn't even
lost of us to Nintendo came out and they
did the impossible they made everyone
excited about Rabbids and Mario crossing
over we've always wondered what could
happen if our crazy rabbits were
unleashed upon the world of Mario today
the dream is reality
[Applause]
they also had a lot of heartwarming
moments you know they had that moment
where you know the Rabbids guy was
looking at me Amato talking about his
game and just cried when I met David a
song I had just just one condition for
this project the cycle judges of the
game prepare so you put up the home
games are not there Mario de mama
discovered on an agenda no game or see
guys I said whatever you do don't try to
make a jump game or a Mario platformer
try to make a Mario game that has never
been made before in terms of the games
and also kind of the feeling and the
atmosphere Ubisoft undoubtedly won a
three for me for me the winner this
year's e3 would have to be Michel on
sale
I mean Beyond Good and Evil came out
well over ten years ago and the fans
have been desperate for a sequel and
they always kind of said like it's never
happening or he's never getting round to
it so him to come out at the end of us
Oscar press conference and to have it be
the big surprise and you saw how
emotional and choked up he got I thought
that was incredible and I think III this
year was a definite win just for him and
also a special thanks to the fans of
being good and evil for sticking with
that for so long about bloody time 15
years like if you want a really personal
win for III it has to be Michelle on
stuff if I had to pick I would say
Nintendo I think that the other
conferences were missing a little
something special with Nintendo they
showed that brevity is really what works
in a conference it was quick and it was
didn't overstay its welcome we got
things like Metroid Pokemon on switch we
got more info on Super Mario Odyssey
which looks phenomenal and I was just
hoping for a little bit more out of Sony
for example I wanted to see The Last of
Us - I wanted to see something that we
really hadn't seen des des was the same
way
so with Nintendo there were a few
surprises there were more details on
things we knew about we got a little bit
of everything
those are just a few of our thoughts on
this year's e3 winners but we'd like to
hear yours feel free to add them below
and if you'd like to stay up to date on
our e3 game impressions give us a sub
thanks for watching
[Music]